Although George Gamow thought information would be stored
most efficiently in the overlapping model. In reality
the triplet code is read in the non-overlapping
fashion. Actually, the less efficient method. Now, obviously, if
we were designing a system, this doesn't make
a lot of sense, as far as efficiency's sake,
right? We can get more information stored in
this overlapping model than compared this non overlapping model
where each codon has to be its own individual or its own discreet unit. And
it turns out that this messiness, this
inefficiency is a result of evolution. And in
particularly some molecular constraints of the system
that are slightly beyond the scope of our
material here. So that means that we're left
with 64 possible combinations of three nucleotides and
each set of three is referred to as a
codon. So we have 64 possible codons. And a codon
is just a sequence of the three nucleotides that
are part of the genetic code. And, it took years
of experiments to finally determine which codons code for
which amino acids. And this information is referred to as
the genetic code. Although it took many years and a
lot of hard work to come up with this information.
I'm giving it to you, right here, summarized for free in
less than a few seconds. Here is all of the magic of
the genetic code. You'll going to have to get quite familiar with
this table so, I hope it doesn't scare you away too fast.
I've color coded it to try to make it a little
simpler for you. And I'll explain to you how to read it
in just a moment. But the first thing that I want
you to do is actually just stare at it for a minute.
Try to read it. First letter in the
codon, second letter in the codon, third letter in
the codon. We have UCAG, UCAG, and then
each combination for every row here. And then you
can see each codon is spelled out. In
the individual box and then beside it is the
amino acid that it codes for. What patterns or
features stand out to you about this genetic code?
Is there anything interesting that you notice? I
want you to use the text box here
to describe any kind of response you have
that might answer this question. And don't worry about
getting this right or wrong. I just want to see what you pick up on. You
could always go to the forum and see
what other people think about the genetic code too.